Not necessarily. Remember, these data are purely correlational. We can't make
causal statements using these data, for the reasons described at the end of
lesson 14. Remember, correlation versus causation? Anyway, there are many
variations of multiple regression. Including ways of adding or dropping
predictor variables. Deciding what variables should be included in the final
equation, types of criterion variables, etcetera. It's often difficult to
account for all the possible factors that could influence the dependent
variable. Maybe if you go on to more advanced statistics classes, you'll get to
learn those methods, but now you have a basic understanding of a very complex
topic. Great job!